as we told you limang Yang was one of
the first people to tell the truth in
the United States a great personal cost
she was there she joins us now doctor
thank you so much for coming on you said
three years ago that you believed that
this virus was intentionally released by
the government you once worked for the
government of China
today we're hearing in this leak to the
Wall Street Journal that it was
accidental do you believe this leak was
accidental or intentional
hi Tucker thank you for having me again
first I really want to appreciate you
and also Fox News have been taking so
much efforts pursuing the truths of Kobe
the origin without your help there won't
be such Milestone achievement and I want
pair of course it was not an accident
and maybe for people who don't have this
kind of biosity labs three or four
experience experience on chronovirus
maybe it's easy for them to accept the
accident and left League however I'm the
scientist working in such lab using
chronovirus and I can tell you based on
the print protocol and also the other
surveillance system it will be
impossible for the map League
accidentally happened in such lab and
because the Wuhan outbreak and also the
pandemic so definitely now we just reach
to the first step it was from China's
lab and we need to pursue the truth of
origin and we need to keep going on
we know the Chinese government allowed
its infected citizens to travel in huge
groups to Western Europe in the early
days of the pandemic that was
intentional but you believe the whole
thing they came up with this virus and
they Unleashed it on the World to
destroy the Western economies and to
elevate their own position globally
on uh emphasize one thing is I would say
based on the evidence and the thoughts I
have that the lab the virus was
intentionally brought out of this strict
map and released in the community
however I don't think the outbreak in
Wuhan was intentional I would say it was
because CCP government and Military
scientists underestimate the
transmissibility that's why finally it
gets out of control and cause the motor
local outbreak however we should know
that CCP government intentionally to
make it go all over the world to kill
millions of people all over the world
later
we just have to hope and pray that you
will be interviewed by many other
journalists in this country over the
coming weeks now that this has been
confirmed you're an eyewitness to it you
have a I think a credible story to tell
and I and I really hope you're no longer
ignored I appreciate you're coming on
again tonight leaving Young thank you so
much
thank you Tucker subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight